що на пити голова ним віце-прем'єра за
монетарних за танями Олександровича було
сіно рада диво прогулююча харчування
проведення в суп та компанії
донатики та луганській областях два дні
тому
міністерством святим та наукою України
була видана на косі крем волосся косого
на дроти не йдуть від кови та сесії на
донбасі в цеху новий ізар син на
донбасі нажаль проїзд до зубкової сесії
там просто на йому зла его і через на йому
жилось тиран туго the base пайку
учасники в той бік і через нас потрібна
віза ран туго так бачите низ
тестових матеріалів саме цьому було
прийнято ці складні рішення просто су
вони йдуть від кову you сесії та камала
проходять з великого 15
посмішка була канадські ланські області на
тому місці абітурієнтам із донбасу було
рекомендовано перерві стр-во тис вона
проходить залози на у dota такого щастя
кабуто в паршиво до 15 липня
venture він і за 36 тисяч абітурієнтів з
донбасу
стану на сьогодні парі реєструвався
крихтою більше 17000 пучковий термін
перереєстрації bulb1 завершення пари
istrati ебу 15 чари дня ми продовжимо і
twitter мін до 20 год рівня
сьогодні-завтра абітурієнтів донбасу
знімають знову перереєстрацію на
проходження зоні шина закладеної тіні
вання та ще райони
міністерство святі наук ці слова бога
встиг пройти з вищого початкового за
скарбом та гаранту я чоловік вивести постояла
нібур теж так для тих абітурієнтів з
донбаса річки пройдуть проходить азанова
venture він і розум стиму на бити ворога
вивчиш усе за сьогодні-завтра США
in абітурієнтів з віри та струмує ми
розуміємо ще завищується частини на
абітурієнти річки
не зможе на перебудуватися не пройдуть він
ще на закладену тіні манії в
тут від кову сесію інша проблема
сауна за раз я затягну починається стіна
університу йти в донецькій та луганській
області боятися та відкривалася
направлення в ступні компанії і через
бас постараюся не по грози
каримо накаму овочі в початкових закладах та
залом через ту ж на пружину
військово-політичну ситуацію ми розуміємо
та шоу університети собою у всіх районах
давай дути і активніше вайаніді і він і
вас причин не може функції на вати в
терміновому режимі на сьогодні у нас їжі
Кіліка
випадки в кулер і які ви машині 1
тис а через прикмети загрози людей з брови
річки приходять і не даєте чи можна праворуч
дати начальник процес її занурюсь у
язичну праву ви підходите будете
новий не винна на роботу українських
вищих початкових закладах цеху мова оба
зварювального проводить і вступну компанію
було б тугіше і тугіше складно тому сьогодні
на радіо було прийнято таке рішення
університету в донецьку та луганську та
області ранку йому ці чоловіки є
подібні терміни
завершення в ступні і компанії давай
раз ними мережі
місяця маються можемо матом і тьму жвавість
раз купа то її поставлено титова вул японія
обидва пісні ш
заклади на вигляд обставлений цьому
конкретному місці тупцюють університети
у цій осі куди ситуація бішма ж
стабільно він може звучати прийом
документів про дано квітів посмішка алла
завершить он і повинні лише 1 день 1
година нам по всій подане лютневі
області в vr з ними мережі розум знімки
університету та keys знаходяться в зонах
активних військових ідей обидва даємо через те
ви для того щоб починати джордана
відставав і плюс велику компанію
він і ранок мати можна вести що пісні
кулі звучать і прийом документів
вірмен
дата початку прийому документа означати
україни університетом шляхи починатися
посмішки і далі вже як вони ви означає
завершення прийому документів буду без
she wore з ними мережі для псих
університеті в донецькій та луганській
області для tedx абітурієнтів
berry ховався обидва перебудовувалися
олл-іни зможе з класно ковою
союзу зовнішню закладено у тіні в
університетах на Донбасі
буду організована у крему сесія
сонячно на закладену синього не витрачаючи
сесія факт прокинутися
на заміну патенту ним жвавості у ступнях
і спати і до ранку було витка на те
скільки викинуто за великим рахунком було
за права членів ступні випробування
c надавала в гості об'єктивного
хлопець нянею від їхніх абітурієнтів вікі
стрибати результатом і сина, і туфельки
пройдете будуть створювати їх ступні та
спад і подруга була б проблема стем
що будуть поки що не готова наскільки
зоря і на корм кого але проходив їх
ступні тому через
і третій аргумент, що ви підключитися
буду все-таки витрачаються сезону в
університетах при шкірному університеті
буду організована то в такому тортурі
результату зошит з осі та результатів
їх тіла дістання абітурієнти зможете
викури стати і в тому університеті
досить будуть проходу то наново і в
найкращих університетах донецької луганської
області і збутися було просто у ступні
esp це надзвичайно subbable ступні спад
води на університет на одну дві
спеціальності точно
абітурієнта the deep був з усього
множення можна
гості вступати до найвищих початкових
закладі в пурим не нашим абітурієнтам
які мають право на 15 заявок ви всі
чудово знаєте там у
буду організовано третю сесію
українському центру синього не опустила
почти готові та провести
фінансово не так. там ще через касу
вони дадуть до висмоктання на донбасі краще
футболу закон про планету кішки річки по ви
не було лиха на звідси до такого щастя
тома біт буде витрачаючи соси абітурієнти
вранці цим уже ловиш складу ти і спад
у цеху університету
без побудови дата дроту не атрофію
сесії будуть його значення далі без
ніші тому щоб вона буде до великої
світу закласти в тому числі виду військову
ідей на території донбасу будуть
а крім рішення та міністерство святі
ну-ка дайте харчування будуть внески тася
знову на кабінет міністрів з тим що
ворогові лева that's про ітан я все-таки
максимальну за їх умов наскільки чоловіки
його запас втрати права абітурієнта
донецької та луганської області